12 عاما مرت على هذه اللحظه لحظه الاعلان
عن استضافه خطر لكاس العالم
ورفقتها حملات تعارض الاستضافه لكنها
تحولت الى هجمات مكثف منسقه بين وسائل
الاعلام اسرائيليه الغربيه حتى اخر ساعه
تسبق مباراه الافتتاح
الصحف العبريه الاسرائيليه هاجمت
المونديال هذه عينه من رسوم الكاريكاتير
التي نشرت هذه
الصحيفه التي اول صدور لها من يعني اقدم
الصحف في اسرائيل اول صدور لها في عام 39
هذا كان كثير اخر لصحيفه اسرائيل اليوم من
اكثر الصحف الاسرائيليه انتشاره صحيفه
ثالثه وهي جلوبس العبريه اختارت نشره هذا
الكاريكاتير ايضا لكن المقامات والاعمده
لم توفر فرصه ثانيه مهاجمه قطر
من
الذين كتبوا
بندورو يميني يقول مرحبا بكم في مونديال
العار هذا هو عنوان المقال لكن في متن
يقول ستصبح البلاد المظلمه الاكثر لمعانا
في الشهر القادم قطر دوله
عدو ليس لوجود قناه الجزيره فيها التي
تحرض وانما لانها تدعمه الاسلام
الراديكالي صحيفه اخرى وهي صحيفه
تقول قبل انطلاق المباراه في الدوحه
الجانب المظلم لاحتفالات كره القدم في قطر
تقرير للقناه الثالثه عشر الاسرائيلي يقول
اربعه اسباب بعدم السفري الى من ديالى قطر
دعونا نتابع ما قاله المغردون العرب بشان
الحمله الاعلاميه الاسرائيليه على كاس
العالم
الكيان الصهيوني يقول لك رضا ياسين قالت
هنا صهيوني يستمر بتحريضه ضد قطر
هذا يعني انها في الطريق صحيح ادهم ابو
سليمه لديه هذه التغريده يقول فيها القيام
الصهيوني هو احد اخطر المحرضين ضد قطر
بالمشاركته مع دول العربيه هذا الحقد
الصهيوني نابع من الرغبه في عدم اظهار
صوره مشرقه لهذه المنطقه ليلى ابو زيد
ليلى ابو زيد اذا بحثت قطر في المستقبل
بعد نجاح تنظيمها للمونديال ان شاء الله
ستجد انا وراءها حمله الشر في جميع
البلدان هو اللي هو الصهيوني ويمكن ان
تحاكمه اذا وجدت دليلنا على تشويه الكذب
محمد عيد
الاسرائيلي ليس فقط صراعا عسكريا صراعنا
ثقافي واقتصادي كل نجاح عربي الفكر
الصهيوني ياللي ساهم بتشويه الوطن العربي
شكرا قطر
ومن ارضها كان هناك قناه اسرائيليه شاركت
في الحمله الاعلاميه ضدها هنا مثلا مذيعون
اسرائيليون استضاف المغني الكولومبي
مالوما الذي يؤدي احد الاغاني الرئيسيه
لكاس العالم فاتوره للانسحاب وصفا المقدم
بالواقع
اي جزء
لعبه